[Applause]
you know how it works I give you two
stories most Applause decides which one
we do that easy First Option economists
say rising debt could weigh heavily on
the Eurozone GDP audience you like that
one huh
all right
second option a Delta flight made an
emergency landing because a passenger
had diarrhea
all right
all right all right I get you I got you
I feel it
I don't know how many times I have to
say this but diarrhea wins
so uh cat uh last Friday at Delta jet
from Atlanta going to bartha Barcelona
not Barcelona Barcelona it'd be the was
two hours into its flight when it turned
around and flew back to Atlanta the
pilot called it a biohazard issue uh uh
I don't know what happened to six
pastors but apparently the smell was so
bad the captain instructed the crew to
light a match
so
I actually think this story is really
inspiring you go okay because
so this person I guess all over the
plane yeah yeah and there's been no
updates on this person this person
hasn't been identified but as long as
they have not killed themselves
all of us can always move on from
anything right exactly could you imagine
being the person who
all over a plane
you know to the point where the flight
had to be grounded and you had to get up
and leave and everybody knows it was you
yeah
and they wanted to go on their nice
little Spain trip nope diarrhea guys are
everywhere
and it's not even your own diarrhea it's
somebody else the other person they
probably feel I don't know I hope that
diarrhea person assuming they're still
alive uh you know went to Spain and like
feels okay because you know if you do if
you can get over that we all can get
over anything that ever comes at us in
our lives they should have diverted the
plane to San Francisco yeah
the more
I watch a lot of Forensic Files
emergency road at night in my hotel and
the more we're hearing this story
somebody else was missing around this
time too cat oh
[Music]
I feel like this was the greatest prank
he ever did anywhere he took a week off
of work he trained he ate everything he
could just to go on a trip to Barcelona
and go oh oh guys
oh the door doesn't lock oh what are we
gonna do
somewhere
whoever this person is
probably feeling pretty proud of himself
I've had thoughts about this Kennedy you
know this happening this is why I do not
like like the idea of before a flight
getting like a super burrito and a big
tall latte from Starbucks and just
guzzling it doesn't get down and you had
a hangover and then you and then you
have a slice of pizza and then you can
still get out and then it just
starts gurgling yeah swirling inside you
yeah the end of like Hunter Biden
spraying paint
is that what his paintings are made of
is it like ships that are buying them is
that why they're so expensive what do
you think what do you uh uh what do you
make I actually I understand the Panic
have we all forgotten the Ebola outbreak
what was it 20 2014 yeah 2015 when if
you were on a plane and you were
sweating they they would they would kick
you off and and put you in a bubble and
you couldn't see your family for a year
so it's like it's awesome I mean I'm
exaggerating for a fact but that's
that's what these people are thinking
like the reason it's a biohazard issue
because they're like we we don't know if
that's mixed with blood right like we
don't know what other fluids are coming
out now I'm gonna have a meeting
tomorrow with management are you talking
about feces and blood again Greg
like that's everyone's like if they shut
down the schools for coven what in the
hell are they going to shut down for
Ebola I'm not living through that just
turn the plane around and clean it and
kick everyone off what I don't
understand is how is it all over the
plane like if you're having an explosive
diarrhea probably not the best time to
like try to get your steps in yeah
that's true
[Applause]
no I believe the flush wasn't working oh
my God I'm just seeing it in my head now
and it's grossing me out right you know
your your seasoned Traveler
well you've been in the military correct
so you've had not normal for the
military but I'm sure you've been in
situations where the bathroom
accommodations were not suitable when
you had an experience like this do you
ever have explosive diarrhea in a
helicopter oh my God
no but but when I was thinking about the
story I was wondering if that person
also lost access to the duty-free store
in the airport what do you think Arabic
what do you think I'm glad you said that
not me once you break the seal there's
nothing you can do yeah if the bathroom
is full in the back you gotta Sprint to
the front
and it's like you know all right I hope
they had that first that first that
first class attendant who breaks no
rules for nobody
day just holds the curtain no sir you
can't come in here you can't come in
here
and then
sir
[Laughter]
you know I think no lessons could be
learned from this
no one ever says that but we hope that
the passenger got better and is doing
fine and we see that person as a real
hero
further
proves my point
me
all right we're gonna move on have we
haven't grossed you out yet from
chameleons to giraffes our friends bring
the laps hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else